cinéma avec la sortie sur les écrans de
buongiorno notte le dernier film de
marco bellocchio à un retour sur l'une
des pages noires de l'histoire de
l'italie
c'était en 1978 l'assassinât d'aldo moro
le chef de la démocratie chrétienne
italienne par les brigades rouges ce
n'est pas un film historique mais marco
bellocchio apporte quelques éléments de
réflexion à travers les questions lé
doute d'une chaise terroristes richard
tripots et jean-bernard hier le 16 mars
1978 le jour même où il doit signer avec
le parti communiste un accord historique
aldo moro le chef de la démocratie
chrétienne est enlevé par les brigades
rouges
un groupe de brega liste le séquestre
dans un appartement de rome commence
alors 55 jours de huis clos entre aldo
moro et ses ravisseurs seulement rythmée
par les bulletins du journal télévisé
demanderait tiara est l'une des
genouillères d'aldo moro
elle est l'une de ces nombreuses femmes
qui ont participé à l'histoire de ce
groupe terroriste d'extrême gauche
4 les jours passant la tension est de
plus en plus grande dans l'appartement
malgré l'appel du pape les brigadistes
ont décidé d'exécuter aldo moro chiara
tentent de s'opposer à la mort de
l'otage la paix sera it cool
le personnage de chiara n'est pas comme
certains brigadistes qui ont condamné
l'exécution d'aldo moro des raisons
politiques en estimant qu'il s'agissait
d'une erreur
chiara elle y opposent en écoutant plus
ses sentiments et sonner mozy longue que
sa raison je considère de morlaàs sont
restés sept
dispersés a récolté l'état refuse à
aucune négociation mais tous les
historiens disent qu' à partir de là à
commencer la décadence des grands deux
parties aliens la démocratiser l
ex-parti communiste bonne journaux noté
n'est pas une reconstitution historique
mais plutôt une réflexion sur une
tragédie humaine de tentatives pour
comprendre et dénoncé le fanatisme
politique que bellocchio rapproche du
fanatisme religieux